- What's up everybody?
Welcome to another YouTube Hangout.
Super excited to be here.
I have a special guest with
me, Mr Dan Pena known as
the $50 billion man.
Because the people who he
has coached have went on
to create $50 billion plus
in wealth for themselves
and the world.
He is a coach, he is an
author, he is a speaker,
he's got a speaking tour right now.
He's sometimes controversial, so we'll see
what we get into today, Mr
Dan Pena, welcome aboard!
- Thank you for having me.
It's nice to see your face
other than on a website,
more or less in person.
Thank you very much for having me.
- I love it, so for the
people who may not have
heard of you yet, we've
done some videos on you,
but for the people who still
don't know, Mr Dan Pena,
a little bit beyond the intro I gave you,
how would you introduce yourself?
What do you want to say?
- Well, I'm a,
barrio bad boy, I came from the
barrio of East Los
Angeles, as a adolescent,
got in a lot of trouble.
Who got flunked out of
university three times,
arrested five times,
went off and the military
made a man of me, in fact,
today is a very special day.
50 years ago today, one June, 1967,
by an act of congress, of
the United States of America,
I was deemed an officer and a gentleman,
a second lieutenant.
- All right.
- So 50 that was
(audio muting) high performance thing
that I ever achieved 'cause I didn't think
flunking out of school
and getting arrested
was much of an achievement, although my
buddies thought I was cool.
And that's why I tell
kids, show me your friends
and I'll show you your future.
I went on, came back from the military,
came back to school,
graduated with honors,
ultimately finished four year degree
in two and a half years, went on,
had a scholarship to go to
law school I never used,
and went on to Wall Street,
and the rest is more or less history.
And
I've created since 1993, my
24th anniversary was last week,
when I gave my first seminar.
And my kids, like you have
created over $50 billion in
equity and value in those 24 years.
And I was just on the
phone with one of them
who's created billions and
he wishes you all well,
and he says, you'll
need it under the whip!
I'm the whip.
- [Evan] I like it.
- Yeah and,
I've just started a tour of
the United States and Canada,
and I'll be visiting your
hometown in a few months,
where I go to speak at
universities for free pro bono.
They don't pay for me to get there
or anything like that, they
don't put me up in a hotel.
And I got the idea, Evan,
when Oxford University
called me last year, and
I had speciously said,
oh must be my Rhodes
Scholarship, 50 years late.
You know?
But I went to speak
there, and it was a very
successful event.
And then I got the idea
well, if Oxford liked it,
maybe a lot of other people would like it.
But I was booked up all
the rest of last year
and so I only started giving
these talks to schools.
But everything I have
on my website is free,
99.9% of all the kids that I've
created the $50 billion with
I've never met because
all my product's free.
I don't sell anything other
than the Castle Seminar,
and then I mentor you for a year free.
But,
I mean the big thing about today is,
information's almost instantaneous,
actually it is instantaneous.
Like this, you're in
Canada and I'm in Scotland,
and we're able to do a show like this.
And I think it's terrific.
I take my hat off to you.
- I love it, so let's get to the topic.
I always have my guests pick the topic.
I don't really cover politics
a lot on this channel.
You know I always feel like entrepreneurs,
we're the ones that's going
to solve all the problems
of the world, not to
rely on the president,
or the government, or not
to blame the president
for your not having success.
Right like, I'm not a
success because of Trump
or because of Obama or
because of anybody else,
I think is ridiculous.
And so it's interesting to
cover politics on this channel,
I'd love to know why you picked this topic
and what your thoughts are.
- Well, on November eighth, I announced,
when he was elected, now, full disclosure,
I knew President Trump
in a different life.
I knew him in the late '80s and early '90s
when I was partners with people
that he knew in New York.
But I haven't seen
President Trump in 25 years.
So OK.
But on November eighth,
I said that this was
the greatest transformation
of wealth in the history
of the world since World War II.
And the reason why he was
elected in my judgment,
and I was one of the first
to endorse him, publicly.
Is that the United States is fed up,
you know, I'm not here
to talk bad about Obama,
although I didn't think
he did much, but anyway,
and just fed up, just
like Brexit in the UK,
and various other votes.
But I know what he's capable
of, both good and bad,
and I know,
most people listening here,
if they're US citizens,
have no idea what it
really means if we get
from 35 to 50 or 20% corporate tax rate.
You have no conception what that means.
I mean in the trickle down effect.
So I mean the Trump era, and
he may only stay one term,
but the Trump era, he's already
made tremendous changes.
And if he's done nothing more than
we can have change if the people rise up.
We can have change if the people rise up.
Now, as another aside,
I knew the first Trudeau
back in the day, probably
before you were born.
And I had the pleasure of meeting him.
And just as I also have
met five presidents,
five secretaries of state, and
I also met, as a little boy,
General de Gaulle.
So when you've been around a
million years, like I have,
you've met a lot of people, and that's why
the perspective that I give, and I believe
why I was so successful at Oxford,
and I'm going to be successful
at these other schools,
and that's why the kids come here.
My demographics for this
seminar, Evan has changed.
10 years ago it was mid 30s to late 40s.
The demographics for the
seminar now is late teens
to late 20s.
- [Evan] Hmm.
- Late teens to late 20s.
- And why the shift?
- Two things, I believe.
One the kids can make
money on the internet
to pay for it, although we
give students a big discount
and we give active duty
military a big discount,
that's number one.
And number two, they know
that they're pissed off
earlier now, they know they're not happy.
And people only make a change
for one or two reasons,
you know, inspiration or desperation.
And to come to me because I'm really hard,
to come to me you have to have tried
everybody and their dog.
I've had kids come here
that have read 700 books.
And in 700 books they couldn't
figure what the fuck to do.
So they come to me.
And the most important aspect
in my coaching, teaching,
mentoring is the one
year free mentor program,
and I give it free because
I want to be able to
throw you out if you don't measure up.
I take exception to people
that say it's a boot camp.
Most of these kids have never
been to a fucking boot camp.
They wouldn't know a boot camp
if it bit them in the butt!
But I mean, we're hard here.
Like the kids can't go to the
gymnasium until they earn it.
I have two gymnasiums here at the castle.
It's hard.
But I find life hard and,
if you look back upon the
Elon Musks, et cetera,
of this world, the current
day, they're tough guys,
they're not, you know, wusses.
You know, they're not
snowflakes I think is the word.
I had to look that up, I
wasn't sure what that meant.
But they're not snowflakes.
And most people come here, I'm told,
because I'm an alpha male dad
model that they never had.
I'm not asking for any kids,
I got three lovely children,
I don't need any.
But one of the reasons
that I have admiration
for President Trump, look at his kids.
They should be spoiled brats.
Now I'm not saying they're
not spoiled in a certain way
but they've got their
heads on their shoulder,
they've got their own business.
My kids should be spoiled brats.
But they're not, they're
successful in their own,
I didn't get any of my children jobs,
I didn't make one phone call.
And they went to good schools.
You don't have to go to school.
We have kids that come here
that didn't get out of high school.
The point is that I make you accountable.
I'm the only, that I
know of, and correct me
if you know of anybody else
that makes their seminar
attendees and post seminar, for one year,
to be 100% accountable.
100%.
Not 98%.
Through their weekly reporting
and their monthly Zoom calls.
It's very much like the military.
And, the only thing is
I don't hit 'em anymore.
In the '90s, I hit ya.
Now I don't.
I'd still like to hit ya.
But now for obvious reasons,
everybody's got an iPhone.
Although, we don't let you
have your iPhones in the room,
but anyway, be that as it may, right now,
there's a whole room
full of them sitting over
in the main castle waiting to come
and me giving them a beatin'!
Or a beat down.
And we've even got some Canadians!
The Canadians love me, I don't
know why, why they should.
I normally don't have anything
good to say about Canada but,
other than I made a lot of money there.
And yourself, who's been kind enough to
talk about me over the years.
And like my 10 secrets, et cetera.
I think it's a very unique
concept that you have.
And I think you bring a
lot of service to the kids.
But at the end of the day
they've got to take action.
They can watch all the YouTubes, podcast,
from now until they bury them.
And if they don't take action it's all BS.
The Dalai Lama had his
80th birthday last year.
Were you invited, by the way?
- I was not invited.
- Neither was I.
But some of my high performers were.
And at the end of the speech
he says meditation is great.
Prayer is great, contemplation is great.
But if you don't take
action, action, action,
all the rest is wasted.
And what the kids today have trouble with,
they connote reading a
book to taking action.
And I'm not saying you shouldn't read
'cause I've read the classics,
I've read Shakespeare,
and all that stuff.
But it's not taking action.
Taking action is pulling the trigger,
going out and making something happen.
And even if you fail.
And the kids have problems with that.
And they come to me
and I show them the way
through the maze as it were,
how to learn how to take action.
- So let's talk about that.
You've got the guys reading 700 books,
you've got people just watching video
after YouTube video after YouTube video,
but they're not doing anything.
They show up to you, how
do you get that person
who read all the books but
hasn't pulled the trigger
to do something?
- Well first of all, they
pay me a whole bunch of money
to come here, and there's no refunds.
So they pay me a lot of money.
And,
I shame them.
I embarrass them.
Even yourself, high
performer, and by the way,
I call everybody kids
because I'm either old enough
to be your father or grandfather.
A kid like you, if you had to keep track
of seven days a week, 24
hours a day, what you do,
you would be shocked,
astounded, overwhelmed,
or as they say in Britain, gobsmacked,
how much time you waste.
And I make them keep track
of every minute of the day!
Every minute of the day.
And it's not easy.
It's not easy.
And, when you find out,
I have people that have
come to the seminar,
that spend 20 hours a day
walking in the fresh air and meditating.
20 hours a week, excuse me, not a day.
20 hours a week.
And they don't get anything done,
and they don't feel relaxed.
Now I've never meditated
one second in my life.
I've walked in the fresh air.
But unless I'm sweating
and I'm running up a hill,
I don't think I'm accomplishing much.
From a cardio point of view.
At my age, I should be
strolling, up the hill,
or not even going up the hill.
So we make 'em accountable,
we give 'em the templates,
we give them the tools.
For those that even didn't read 700 books,
they've read seven books or 20 books,
you've read about all the
various financial instruments.
But here we teach you
how to play the entire
financial orchestra for the first time.
Money is almost free the
last eight or nine years.
Yet it's hardly I find a snowflake
that has done anything about it.
Free, the money's free right now!
10, 20 years from now,
Evan, the guys on this call,
their kids and grandkids
are going to ask 'em,
what the fuck did you do when the money
was being given away free?
Dad, granddad?
I did nothing, I just
kept my finger up my ass,
and read another book.
I mean,
I don't know how much longer this
is going to last, free money,
but right now, there is
so much money out there,
it's unbelievable.
The problem the kids
have when they come here,
and not just when they
come here, they don't know
what a real deal looks like.
They really don't know that
(sighing) free cash flow
has to cover debt service.
They don't understand that concept.
And they come in here with PhDs, MBAs,
they're certified financial
analysts, you name it
we've had 'em here.
And they just don't understand.
As I said, they wouldn't know a deal
if it bit 'em in the butt.
And they spend most of their time on deals
that intellectually sound good but,
financially they're no good.
And so once you learn
the difference between
a deal and not a deal, and
once you learn for real,
and we show you the templates to use
to how to get the money out of the banks,
your life is never the same,
it's just never the same.
- And why now?
So you say free money right
now, it's not going to last,
next generation, what's
so special about right now
where it's free money?
- Because interest rates
are so damn low!
I mean interest rates are giving it away!
I mean, I was making money, millions,
when interest rates were 15, 18, 20%!
Not two, three, four percent.
I mean they're literally, the
only thing they're not doing
is setting up, like the
Bank of America founder,
the picture you've got in the back,
he said, if I remember correctly,
after the great fire, San
Francisco Fire of 1906 or five
or whatever it was, he set up a card table
outside the bank, or what
was left of the bank,
they were making loans.
And people still didn't
even come up to him.
He didn't even do all
the paperwork like now.
I mean, oh God,
I take a jet plane, I'd
be the number one in line
to do business with that old timer.
But I mean it's not that easy,
but I mean it's real easy.
Another thing, in America,
the Small Business Administration, the SBA
in recent years has gone from
a one million dollar limit
to a five million dollar limit.
Meaning the government
guarantees your damn loan.
And there's talk, under Trump,
I don't know if it's true,
that it's going to go
to seven or 10 million.
If you can't do a deal when
the government's going to
guarantee 100% of the goddamn thing,
you ought to blow your brains out!
You ought to commit seppuku,
I think it's called.
As Elon Musk said, he
would rather commit seppuku
which is, harikari, than fail!
And I mean,
I don't know how long it's
going to last, I don't.
But I do know that it's here now.
And God almighty, I don't
know why you wouldn't
want to take advantage of it.
As long as it's moral, ethical and legal.
Moral, ethical and legal.
Those are my only backstops.
- I like it.
- But if you don't want to
be moral ethical and legal,
God almighty.
It'd be the mafia!
- I like that you know your history!
Most people have never
heard of AP Giannini,
and being able to pull
that story out was great,
it was actually across two
barrels and a plank of wood,
and he would lend money to people
based off of a handshake
and a look in their eye.
That's how you got a
deal with AP Giannini.
He wanted to judge a man by
the callouses on his hand,
that's how he made a decision
whether to give a loan or not.
So, far cry from
- All they have
are callouses on their fingertips maybe
from being on the laptop.
(laughing)
- Let's talk about that, so I mean,
I got AP Giannini behind me.
I love learning from successful people,
trying to apply to my life, my business.
I see behind you you've
got this giant wall
called influencers, and on there you have
some controversial figures, you've got,
I saw Winston Churchill
and Jesus Christ and JFK.
You have Adolf Hitler,
Einstein, Trump, Ted Turner,
talk to me, you're
pulling from a wide range
of people who are all over the place.
- Stalin, I've got Stalin, I've got,
oh Walt Disney, Jack Welch, I mean,
McNamara from the Vietnam
era who I actually knew but
all those people now, when they ask me,
what have I read?
I read them.
What did I look at last night
to get fired up for today,
for tonight?
I watched the two and a half
hour movie, 1963 movie Zulu,
with Michael Caine,
which depicted 1779 I believe,
Africa, the British army,
where they fought off
5000 Zulus, 150 guys,
and they did heroic stuff.
That's what fires me up because it's tough
to keep your energy high and fired up
because I've done just about
everything known to man,
I have.
Not all good shit, but I mean, I've done
just about everything known to man.
But the reason I have these
people is because I learn
something from everybody.
You know, Hitler believed in
practice, practice, practice.
He had over a million photographs of him
to do his promotional
stuff when he was selling
Mein Kampf, and when he was selling
to become chancellor
of Germany in the '30s.
A million pictures.
He was the first guy
being advised by Goebbels
that, you know, if you're
going to influence the masses.
I studied when I was learning,
when I was a poor speaker
30 plus years ago, I studied JFK,
I studied Winston Churchill,
I also studied Hitler
and his mannerisms, but I
couldn't understand what he said.
And I studied to be a world
class speaker that I am today,
or at least I'm told I am today.
I studied Harry Truman who's up here
who was the president that took over
from Franklin Delano Roosevelt
when he died in office
and he was the guy that made the decision
to drop the atomic bomb, bombs.
Can you just imagine the
heaviness of that decision?
The heaviness that you're going to kill
God knows how many people?
I study, in current day I study
Secretary of Defense General
Mattis, Mad Dog Mattis.
And I have some friends
from my military days
that actually know the secretary.
But these are all high profile people.
You may not like 'em,
but they're high performance people,
every single one of them.
Every single one of them.
And quite frankly, in
my judgment, 85 to 95%
of the people that write
books aren't high performance.
They're also rans.
Why do the kids read 'em?
Evan?
Because they say it's easy.
And I mean, high performance
is anything but easy, and
staying on top is even harder
than getting to the top.
Now I've been on the top
of my game, arguably for
three and a half decades.
I haven't had to work in 35 years.
People ask me how do I
get up in the morning?
I get up fired up!
I'm fired up, I've been
high on life since 1974,
that I thought about it, and actually
since I got that OCS 50 years ago today.
Failure's not an option.
And I do fail.
But when I do fail I'm so fucking,
I can't believe it!
It must be an error!
There must be a typo!
Because I'm so used to winning.
And I've had
the pleasure, the good
fortune, to have been mentored
by some real, real,
world, world, world class guys.
And,
the world class guys like me.
they often say you have the
energy I had 50, 60 years ago.
This is when I was younger.
I went where the action was.
I went to New York.
They said that Wall Street'd
eat me alive, barrio bad boy.
They were wrong.
I run towards the gunfire
and I kill everybody,
metaphorically speaking.
I look for problems.
Because from chaos comes order.
From chaos comes order, and I've done that
successfully for, 50 years.
And, I'll be 72 in a few
weeks, I don't feel 72,
I don't believe I look 72.
And I've had, if you've
noticed on my website,
I'm called the bionic man because I've got
so many artificial parts
in me, my knees, my hip,
my shoulders, my
collarbone, my right bicep.
I mean, I'm running out
of parts to replace.
And that's because I do
everything to the maximum
and I do a lot of physical stuff,
in the past than now where I
got hurt a lot and I busted up.
I'm looking to be all I
can be every single day.
I mean, there's no question.
And getting back to the original question,
how do I change their mindset?
Is because I require the
kids to be all they can be
every single day for one year.
I have 100% track record for
changing lives for the better.
It's much less for billionaires.
It's more for hundreds of millions
and more even that than tens of millions,
and if I can't make you the millionaire,
I'll blow my fucking brains out.
But I mean, a million, the
average little dumpy house
in Los Angeles costs a million bucks now.
I don't know about Canada but...
- It's getting there,
Toronto's pretty expensive.
- When I'm in Toronto, I'll probably stay
at Trump Tower, which I stayed there
last time I was in Toronto,
not because of President Trump.
I don't know how close
that is to the University,
I don't know.
- Close enough.
- I'm making two speeches in Toronto,
one to a group of lawyers I think,
financial, excuse me, financial people,
and one to the university.
And I'm looking forward to it,
I'm expecting different kind of questions
in Canada than I normally get.
- I look at one guy on
the back of your wall,
you got Ray Kroc who's the
guy who built McDonald's,
and he really started that in his 60s.
And at an age when most people
were thinking about retiring,
that's when he's just getting started
to go off and build this huge empire.
People look at you, a guy 72 years old,
still tons of fire, still tons of energy.
What is it that gets you
pumped up to continue to do this.
You've got your castle, you've got all the
material possessions you want.
Why do you wake up every
day and do what you do?
- Because, I'm glad you
asked that question.
Because I want to take as many of you
across the goal line
before they put dirt on me.
My wife says I have a bad back
because I'm carrying all
you fuckers for 25 years.
OK, I want to take as many of you
across the goal line and that's why I give
all my product away free
'cause I want to take
that last excuse.
I went from the most expensive product,
high performance coaching
product on the net, to free.
And I got calls from guys
that you know their names.
Some Canadian, what the
fuck, you're killing us Dan!
Why are you doing that?
'Cause I'm not doing it for them.
And everybody's got the
right to make a living.
I don't want to take that away from them.
But if you can find
anybody that has even done
remotely what I've done, that's coaching,
I'll quit today.
If you can find anybody that even remotely
has made the kind of money
that I've made for others
I'll quit today.
Nobody talks about numbers Evan,
because nobody's created any numbers.
And I know it's gauche, and
money's not the only thing
in life, and I realize that.
If you want to save the
world, go make a ton of money
like Bill Gates, and then save the world.
Like a lot of the big guys
that are saving the world now.
Some say, Evan, that
because they're paying
for the sins that they committed
in creating that wealth.
Now I'm not here to
point the finger because,
you know I support a lot of orphanages.
I have two, 250 nuns praying
for me every single day.
Every single day.
I mean, I do it because I want to,
you want to call it giving back?
I don't call it that.
I'm selfish.
I want to be known, when
they put dirt on me,
as the greatest high performance coach
that ever walked the fucking planet!
I don't even want 'em to
think about Napoleon Hill,
only as an afterthought.
And currently I am.
And I'm not done yet.
You know?
I plan on living to at least 120.
I may not be mentoring at 120,
but I'm six foot one, 225 pounds,
and have twisted steel and panther piss.
I'm still a formidable guy.
And I don't plan on being any
less formidable during my 70s.
Now will I be doing this
in my 80s, I don't know.
I don't know.
But I have no outside investments.
I don't do anything other
than coach the kids.
And why do I not have
any outside investments?
'Cause anybody that's got
a portfolio that thinks
that he can devote to you kids
and over your own investments is a lie.
I have no investments, all I have is cash.
'Cause I never even remotely
want to be conflicted.
You show me one other
person that does that,
I can already tell ya there aren't any.
What about inflation dad?
What about deflation?
(imitating crying) Bullshit!
As Bunker Hunt told me 30 years ago,
one of the real
billionaires, he says Danny,
if you're worrying about paying taxes,
you aint making enough fucking money.
Am I still fired up? Yeah.
And I'm calmed down too.
I've calmed down in my old age.
In the '90s, I loved it
'cause I beat the kids.
I used to, oh God, the good old days.
The good old days.
What's next?
- Well I love the fire and energy
that you still have for us.
We're wrapping up, we're
almost out of time,
it's crazy how quickly
half an hour can go.
For people watching, where
can they learn more about you,
where do you want to guide them to?
You got your website, you
have the success test,
your YouTube channel.
- Yeah, thank you for
reminding me, danpena.com,
all the stuff's free.
Got hundreds of pages,
podcasts, et cetera.
But if you want to separate
the men from the boys
and the girls from the
old women, take my success test.
It's on the front page, the landing page.
And it's only got a 95% accuracy rate,
of correlation to you being successful.
Only 95%.
That's all.
And, you take that test
and then you tell me
how your program's worked up heretofore.
And I want to thank you
Evan for this opportunity.
And I look forward to hopefully seeing you
when I'm in Toronto.
A couple of the
universities I'm speaking at
told me I should be
concerned about my security.
Toronto didn't tell me that so...
- I wouldn't worry too
much about Canadians,
we're usually pretty nice.
So I think you'll have a great time.
- I look forward to it,
I look forward to it
and I look forward to
hopefully meeting you.
- Cool, well Dan, thank you so much
for spending time with
us, guys, go check out
danpena.com, check out that success test
if you want to learn a bit more.
Good luck on your tour Dan and again,
thanks for spending a half
an hour with us today,
we appreciate it.
- OK,
thank you for the opportunity.
Thank you very much.